we're getting reports that security
forces have fired on dozens of
protesters in Baghdad the capital city
under curfew since Thursday after days
of anti-government protests and we're
hearing that were as we said they were
fired on by police on Friday
Imran Khan joins us on the phone from
the Iraqi capital in one what were you
hearing them from the early hours of
Friday morning up until now they've been
various pockets of protesters been
defying the curfew they've been out on
the streets trying to push towards
attackers square in the central factor
that's a focal point for the protesters
they've been fired upon by the Iraqi
security forces have also used tear gas
and water cannons try and disperse them
so what we're seeing now is it's not in
the same kind of number as we saw before
the curfew but it is still very very
significant and very large these
protesters are determined now to keep
the momentum going and to keep trying to
push the TAC risk where it's where that
you've been surrounded by a ring of
armor and the army and the Iraqi
security forces are making sure that
they don't get there so what's happening
is these protests have now been
dispersed in those neighboring streets
and they're are running battles taking
place what's going to happen in the net
in the next coming hours is going to be
crucial the highest religious authority
for Shia Muslims in the country is due
to give a address by his representative
so Friday prayer depending on what he
says if he criticizes the government for
their heavy project Lee says that people
need to join the protest movement and
that means that project will get much
much much larger if use much more
conciliatory and says actually the
protesters need to go home that May will
be listened to by the protest but you
have to understand that this is a
leaderless movement seemingly a
leaderless movement so whether they
actually listen to Ayatollah Sistani is
unclear because they don't have that
kind of organization
and then Ron how are the Iraqi people
likely to view this when they see that
their prime minister on television
trying to calm tensions and assuring
them that their demands are being heard
and and and yet once again this Friday
reports of police firing on protesters
again well the nature of the protest
movement is changing yes the demand is
still there a lot more jobs and more
opportunities we want but much we want
an end to corruption and the Prime
Minister I love the body can say that
your demands have been heard though
we're going to try and introduce a basic
income for the poorest of the society
we're going to make changes within the
government but until there's something
concrete that's not gonna change but the
other thing is that people are very
angry about the amount of death taking
place on the street across Iraq the
latest against justice on 31 people have
been killed that's also fueling the
protest movement because they're now
very angry the fact that the Iraqi
security services and very heavy-handed
tactics so it's not just about listening
to the protesters demands anymore it's
almost a self-fulfilling prophecy the
more people that die in these protests
the more angry the protest was getting
the more determined they are to keep
going all right for the moment Imran
Khan on the lawn on the line for us
there from Baghdad thanks a month